[Musique]
c'est un toc toc toc spécial rock c'est
parti cayla toc toc toc qui est la vigie
c'est qui j gc qui j'ai demandé à la
lune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais là
moi
hervé a vaincu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sale ni samedi qui s'anime lieu dès
samedi
[Applaudissements]
sable
[Musique]
et gilles dutilh glg webradio en fuite
g
eddy médy qui me dit m
et je le sais lola la planète
[Applaudissements]
manille cela mes frères m'ont dit rémy
qui est à roanne et à one by one fans de
bones
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
commentant le coup
non non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que je me trompe si je dis que
vous avez fait espagnol première longue
ça ouais c'est ça et ben non ça fait
vous pouvez juger ce que c'est des
paroles je pense d'accord - 9 1 que ba
d'esker seddik dit qu'ils ont souffert
[Rires]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]